the closing ceremony of the Southeast
Asian Games in Phnom Penh on Thursday
leading proceedings Cambodian prime
minister Hansen now the longest serving
prime minister in the world
the country will hold a general election
in July in which his party will be
virtually unchallenged
the largest opposition party the
candlelight party has been banned from
standing the national election
commission said it had failed to
complete its registration
when the candlelight party is absent it
does seem to limit People's Choice this
is something that we see as an injustice
and part of the killing of democracy in
Cambodia and it should not have been
done
the candlelight party stepped into the
void left by the Cambodian National
rescue party or cnrp which was dissolved
in 2017.
their success in local elections that
year would have posed a serious threat
to Hansen in the next general election
spent six years in detention before
being sentenced to 27 years under house
arrest for treason in March
now that he's gone there's no party or
personality to stand in the way you know
hunsan has obviously gotten used to the
not having any formal political
opposition he likes the fact that you
know the Senate and the Parliament are
completely his that you know he's got
125-0 margin in the lower house uh and I
guess he wants that again
when voters go to the polls in July the
only major party on the ballot will be
hunsen's Cambodian People's Party the
CPP
a democratic process in a single party
statement
I think I thought right because in an
election or a contest there must be a
competitor to compete against each other
to give people a choice or an option
in my opinion one of the big problems is
that we do not have many choices in the
past we had many parties including one
opposition party but now we don't have
real competitors
Hansen may be coming to the end of his
political career he says he'll step down
by 2028 but his son hun Manet already
head of the Armed Forces is running in
this election and is eligible for the
poster prime minister if he wins with no
major opposition that looks like a
pretty good bet Tony Chang Al Jazeera